I've talked a lot about the
importance of hemoglobin in
our red blood cells so I thought
I would dedicate an
entire video to hemoglobin.
One-- because it's important,
but also it explains a lot
about how the hemoglobin-- or
the red blood cells, depending
on what level you want to
operate-- know, and I have to
use know in quotes.
These aren't sentient beings,
but how do they know when to
pick up the oxygen and when
to drop off the oxygen?
So this right here, this is
actually a picture of a
hemoglobin protein.
It's made up of four
amino acid chains.
That's one of them.
Those are the other two.
We're not going to go into the
detail of that, but these look
like little curly ribbons.
If you imagine them, they're a
bunch of molecules and amino
acids and then they're curled
around like that.
So this on some level
describes its shape.
And in each of those groups or
in each of those chains, you
have a heme group
here in green.
That's where you get the
hem in hemoglobin from.
You have four heme groups and
the globins are essentially
describing the rest of it-- the
protein structures, the
four peptide chains
Now, this heme group-- this
is pretty interesting.
It actually is a porphyrin
structure.
And if you watch the video on
chlorophyll, you'd remember a
porphyrin structure, but at
the very center of it, in
chlorophyll, we had a magnesium
ion, but at the very
center of hemoglobin, we have an
iron ion and this is where
the oxygen binds.
So on this hemoglobin, you have
four major binding sites
for oxygen.
You have right there, maybe
right there, a little bit
behind, right there,
and right there.
Now why is hemoglobin-- oxygen
will bind very well here, but
hemoglobin has a several
properties that one, make it
really good at binding oxygen
and then also really good at
dumping oxygen when it
needs to dump oxygen.
So it exhibits something called
cooperative binding.
And this is just the principle
that once it binds to one
oxygen molecule-- let's say
one oxygen molecule binds
right there-- it changes the
shape in such a way that the
other sites are more likely
to bind oxygen.
So it just makes it-- one
binding makes the other
bindings more likely.
Now you say, OK, that's fine.
That makes it a very good oxygen
acceptor, when it's
traveling through the pulmonary
capillaries and
oxygen is diffusing
from the alveoli.
That makes it really good at
picking up the oxygen, but how
does it know when to
dump the oxygen?
This is an interesting
question.
It doesn't have eyes or some
type of GPS system that says,
this guy's running right now and
so he's generating a lot
of carbon dioxide right now in
these capillaries and he needs
a lot of oxygen in these
capillaries surrounding his
quadriceps.
I need to deliver oxygen.
It doesn't know it's
in the quadraceps.
How does the hemoglobin know to
let go of the oxygen there?
And that's a byproduct of what
we call allosteric inhibition,
which is a very fancy word,
but the concept's actually
pretty straightforward.
When you talk about allosteric
anything-- it's often using
the context of enzymes-- you're
talking about the idea
that things bind
to other parts.
Allo means other.
So you're binding to other parts
of the protein or the
enzyme-- and enzymes are just
proteins-- and it affects the
ability of the protein
or the enzyme to do
what it normally does.
So hemoglobin is allosterically
inhibited by
carbon dioxide and by protons.
So carbon dioxide can bond
to other parts of the
hemoglobin-- I don't
know the exact
spots-- and so can protons.
So remember, acidity
just means a high
concentration of protons.
So if you're in an acidic
environment, protons can bond.
Maybe I'll do the protons
in this pink color.
Protons-- which are just
hydrogen without electrons,
right-- protons can bond to
certain parts of our protein
and it makes it harder for them
to hold onto the oxygen.
So when you're in the presence
of a lot of carbon dioxide or
an acidic environment, this
thing is going to let go of
its oxygen.
And it just happens to be that
that's a really good time to
let go of your oxygen.
Let's go back to this
guy running.
There's a lot of activity in
these cells right here in his
quadriceps.
They're releasing a lot of
carbon dioxide into the
capillaries.
At that point, they're going
from arteries into veins and
they need a lot of oxygen, which
is a great time for the
hemoglobin to dump
their oxygen.
So it's really good that
hemoglobin is allosterically
inhibited by carbon dioxide.
Carbon dioxide joins on
certain parts of it.
It starts letting go of its
oxygen, that's exactly where
in the body the oxygen
is needed.
Now you're saying, wait.
What about this acidic
environment?
How does this come into play?
Well, it turns out that most
of the carbon dioxide is
actually disassociated.
It actually disassociates.
It does go into the plasma, but
it actually gets turned
into carbonic acid.
So I'll just write a little
formula right here.
So if you have some CO2 and you
mix it with the water-- I
mean, most of our blood, the
plasma-- it's water.
So you take some carbon dioxide,
you mix it with
water, and you have it in the
presence of an enzyme-- and
this enzyme exists in
red blood cells.
It's called carbonic
anhydrase.
A reaction will occur--
essentially you'll end up with
carbonic acid.
We have H2CO3.
It's all balanced.
We have three oxygens, two
hydrogens, one carbon.
It's called carbonic acid
because it gives away hydrogen
protons very easily.
Acids disassociate into their
conjugate base and hydrogen
protons very easily.
So carbonic acid disassociates
very easily.
It's an acid, although I'll
write in some type of an
equilibrium right there.
If any of this notation really
confuses you or you want more
detail on it, watch some of the
chemistry videos on acid
disassociation and equilibrium
reactions and all of that, but
it essentially can give away
one of these hydrogens, but
just the proton and it keeps the
electron of that hydrogen
so you're left with a hydrogen
proton plus-- well, you gave
away one of the hydrogens so
you just have one hydrogen.
This is actually a
bicarbonate ion.
But it only gave away the
proton, kept the electron so
you have a minus sign.
So all of the charge adds up to
neutral and that's neutral
over there.
So if I'm in a capillary
of the leg-- let me see
if I can draw this.
So let's say I'm in the
capillary of my leg.
Let me do a neutral color.
So this is a capillary
of my leg.
I've zoomed in just one
part of the capillary.
It's always branching off.
And over here, I have a bunch
of muscle cells right here
that are generating a lot
of carbon dioxide
and they need oxygen.
Well, what's going to happen?
Well, I have my red blood
cells flowing along.
It's actually interesting--
red blood cells-- their
diameter's 25% larger than
the smallest capillaries.
So essentially they get squeezed
as they go through
the small capillaries, which a
lot of people believe helps
them release their contents and
maybe some of the oxygen
that they have in them.
So you have a red blood cell
that's coming in here.
It's being squeezed through
this capillary right here.
It has a bunch of hemoglobin--
and when I say a bunch, you
might as well know right now,
each red blood cell has 270
million hemoglobin proteins.
And if you total up the
hemoglobin in the entire body,
it's huge because
we have 20 to 30
trillion red blood cells.
And each of those 20 to 30
trillion red blood cells have
270 million hemoglobin
proteins in them.
So we have a lot
of hemoglobin.
So anyway, that was a little
bit of a-- so actually, red
blood cells make up roughly
25% of all of the
cells in our body.
We have about 100 trillion
or a little bit
more, give or take.
I've never sat down
and counted them.
But anyway, we have 270 million
hemoglobin particles
or proteins in each red blood
cell-- explains why the red
blood cells had to shed their
nucleuses to make space for
all those hemoglobins.
They're carrying oxygen.
So right here we're dealing
with-- this
is an artery, right?
It's coming from the heart.
The red blood cell is going in
that direction and then it's
going to shed its oxygen
and then it's
going to become a vein.
Now what's going to happen is
you have this carbon dioxide.
You have a high concentration
of carbon dioxide in the
muscle cell.
It eventually, just by diffusion
gradient, ends up--
let me do that same color-- ends
up in the blood plasma
just like that and some of it
can make its way across the
membrane into the actual
red blood cell.
In the red blood cell, you have
this carbonic anhydrase
which makes the carbon dioxide
disassociate into-- or
essentially become carbonic
acid, which
then can release protons.
Well, those protons, we just
learned, can allosterically
inhibit the uptake of oxygen
by hemoglobin.
So those protons start bonding
to different parts and even
the carbon dioxide that hasn't
been reacted with-- that can
also allosterically inhibit
the hemoglobin.
So it also bonds
to other parts.
And that changes the shape of
the hemoglobin protein just
enough that it can't hold onto
its oxygens that well and it
starts letting go.
And just as we said we had
cooperative binding, the more
oxygens you have on, the better
it is at accepting
more-- the opposite happens.
When you start letting go of
oxygen, it becomes harder to
retain the other ones.
So then all of the
oxygens let go.
So this, at least in my mind,
it's a brilliant, brilliant
mechanism because the oxygen
gets let go just where it
needs to let go.
It doesn't just say, I've
left an artery and
I'm now in a vein.
Maybe I've gone through some
capillaries right here and I'm
going to go back to a vein.
Let me release my oxygen--
because then it would just
release the oxygen willy-nilly
throughout the body.
This system, by being
allosterically inhibited by
carbon dioxide and an acidic
environment, it allows it to
release it where it is most
needed, where there's the most
carbon dioxide, where
respiration is occurring most
vigorously.
So it's a fascinating,
fascinating scheme.
And just to get a better
understanding of it, right
here I have this little chart
right here that shows the
oxygen uptake by hemoglobin or
how saturated it can be.
And you might see this in maybe
your biology class so
it's a good thing
to understand.
So right here, we have on the
x-axis or the horizontal axis,
we have the partial pressure
of oxygen.
And if you watched the chemistry
lectures on partial
pressure, you know that partial
pressure just means,
how frequently are you being
bumped into by oxygen?
Pressure is generated by gases
or molecules bumping into you.
It doesn't have to be gas,
but just molecules
bumping into you.
And then the partial pressure
of oxygen is the amount of
that that's generated
by oxygen molecules
bumping into you.
So you can imagine as you go
to the right, there's just
more and more oxygen around so
you're going to get more and
more bumped into by oxygen.
So this is just essentially
saying, how much oxygen is
around as you go to
the right axis?
And then the vertical axis tells
you, how saturated are
your hemoglobin molecules?
This 100% would mean all of the
heme groups on all of the
hemoglobin molecules or proteins
have bound to oxygen.
Zero means that none have. So
when you have an environment
with very little oxygen-- and
this actually shows the
cooperative binding-- so let's
say we're just dealing with an
environment with very
little oxygen.
So once a little bit of oxygen
binds, then it makes it even
more likely that more and
more oxygen will bind.
As soon as a little-- that's why
the slope is increasing.
I don't want to go into algebra
and calculus here, but
as you see, we're kind
of flattish, and
then the slope increases.
So as we bind to some oxygen,
it makes it more likely that
we'll bind to more.
And at some point, it's hard for
oxygens to bump just right
into the right hemoglobin
molecules, but you can see
that it kind of accelerates
right around here.
Now, if we have an acidic
environment that has a lot of
carbon dioxide so that the
hemoglobin is allosterically
inhibited, it's not going
to be as good at this.
So in an acidic environment,
this curve for any level of
oxygen partial pressure or any
amount of oxygen, we're going
to have less bound hemoglobin.
Let me do that in a
different color.
So then the curve would
look like this.
The saturation curve will
So this is an acidic
environment.
Maybe there's some carbon
dioxide right here.
So the hemoglobin is being
allosterically inhibited so
it's more likely to dump the
oxygen at this point.
So I don't know.
I don't know how exciting you
found that, but I find it
brilliant because it really is
the simplest way for these
things to dump their oxygen
where needed.
No GPS needed, no robots needed
to say, I'm now in the
quadriceps and the
guy is running.
Let me dump my oxygen.
It just does it naturally
because it's a more acidic
environment with more
carbon dioxide.
It gets inhibited and then the
oxygen gets dumped and ready
to use for respiration.